en face à beaucoup de plaintes de
sociétés assez énorme il est assez
naturel de se sentir impuissant que ce
soit par rapport aux colis de 19 par
rapport au changement climatique par
rapport à l'éthique des algorithmes ou
encore par rapport aux inégalités
sociales
ceci dit dans un livre récent de jeudi
axxon qui s'appelle you want your ride
l'auteur suggère que cette impuissance
ne viendrait pas de nulle part
mais avant de parler de ça il faut avoir
que je vous parle de chiens et
d'électrocution
donc à la fin des années 1960 un
chercheur du nom de martin seligman la
section suivante il a confié constitué
trois groupes de chiens dans un groupe
resté un peu groupe contrôle n'aura rien
fait de particulier dans un second
groupe
il a une prix des chiens ils ordonnaient
des garants des chocs électriques
et puis il y avait aussi un bouton sur
lequel le chien puis appuyez pour
arrêter les chocs électriques et dans le
troisième groupe il y avait eu ces
électrocution et à la suite de cette
phase d'entraînement d'éducation ou
conditionnement en fonction de comment
on va appeler tout ça les chiens étaient
soumis à une autre expérience où il a
été soumis à nouveau à des chocs
électriques et ce qui intéressait martin
seligman c'était de savoir si les chiens
allait essayer de stopper c'est choc
électrique et la découverte de seligman
c'est que tout dépend de cette phase
d'entraînement et en particulier les
chiens qui à qui on avait donné des
chocs électriques sans qu'il puisse rien
faire pour arrêter ces chocs électriques
s'était habitué à ce que les choses sont
comme ça ils vont peut rien y faire et
n'ont pas cherché à stopper les chocs
électriques par la suite et ça ça a
amené martin seligman a parlé de l'homme
alpes la snes en anglais impuissance
apprise s'est traduit comme sur d'autres
questions la page wikipédia
et qui correspond du coup ce phénomène
ou lorsque l'on s'habitue à recevoir des
mots des chocs électriques des punitions
de quelque chose de mal
eh bien on finit par considérer que
c'est la chose normale et qu'on ne peut
rien y faire et en particulier on perd
la capacité de chercher par soi même à
éviter ce genre de punition ou de
douleur bien ce que suggère jeudi
jackson dans son livre c'est qu'il est
en train d'arriver exactement la même
chose
nous autres humains sauf qu'au lieu de
choc électrique
ce sont des mauvaises nouvelles par
rapport à tous ces problèmes de société
et peut-être que trop souvent désormais
on a tendance à se dire les choses sont
comme ça et on ne peut rien y faire
alors ça serait pas forcément un
problème si c'était effectivement comme
ça que les choses se passaient et qu'on
était effectivement un puissant par
rapport à certains problèmes de société
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que
cette vision 13 erronée du monde
elle est extrêmement populaire et
pourtant elle est assez erronée donc je
vous renvoie notamment à cet excellent
tmx de hans rosling au livre de rail
shooting avec spectacle où naissent ou
et présente de nombreuses questions donc
par exemple d'après vous à ce que le
nombre de morts par catastrophes
naturelles dans le monde
ce qu'il a augmenté de puissants depuis
un siècle
ce qui a augmenté est-ce qu'il a diminué
ce qui reste est à peu près le même à
peut-être que ça vous aiguiller si je
vous dis que la proportion des gens qui
m'ont la bonne réponse à cette question
est extrêmement faible
je suis c'est quoi les chiffres mais
c'est très inférieur à 33 % désiste
bestech forme de districts aux afghans
n et goes to tout ce qu'un beau match
[Musique]
des chimistes à sandwich daily news sont
des championnats des veillées des
astuces byron de sweet and the world now
he did you do what you
you have built by the chips on voit à
travers cet exemple que en un sens
nouveau trupin sommes pires qu'ignorant
sur ces questions pourtant assez
importante
nous sommes fiers qu'il n'y aura dans ce
sens où nous penchons nous avons une
intuition et rené de ces problèmes de
société
alors cette vision assez erronée selon
hans rosling joe jackson
ça viendrait de l'actualité en
particulier d'une propriété de
l'actualité également des réseaux
sociaux qu'ils appellent le biais de
négativité qui croient sont simplement
fait qu'on a tendance à beaucoup plus
relayés pour ne plus partager vos plus
écrire sur les catastrophes
une choses qui vont mal les scandales
choses qui ne vont pas plutôt que sur
tous le tout l'amélioration qui garde le
monde est également sur toutes les
pistes d'amélioration qu'il ya surtout
ce que de nombreux gens à travers le
monde font d'incroyable pour essayer de
résoudre ces problèmes les progrès que
ces gens font malheureusement tout ça ça
ne fait pas la une d'el à gré de
l'actualité
donc il ya une expression par an pour
lire les journaux en anglais c'est fx
bleed it leads français ça voudrait dire
si ça saigne alors ça fait la vie donc
ça rime passé un peu moins joli mais je
pense que sa capture bien quelque chose
les tweets qui vont faire 2000 like et
2028 général - c'est plus détruite qui
parle d'un scandale qui révèle un
scandale qui parle d'une catastrophe fin
des choses qui ne vont pas et c'est ça
qu'on met naturellement en avant à la
fois des médias classiques et sur les
réseaux sociaux pour prendre un autre
exemple on veut prendre celui du
changement climatique
c'est vraiment un sujet qui a l'air
tellement énorme et on a l'impression
d'être complètement dépassé et aussi
cette impression qui me semble assez
répandue que y'a rien à faire les choses
n'avancent pas
les gouvernements ne font rien il n'y a
pas de solution à la technologie nous
sauvera pas ainsi de suite cette vision
bien sûr elle n'est pas complètement
faux seins je veux ça n'avance pas aussi
vite que ce qu'elle devrait pour
vraiment combattre réduire
significativement les risques de
changement climatique mais elle est pas
mal non plus complètement juste je pense
qu'il ya eu d'énormes progrès au cours
des mêmes des dernières années d'une
décennie mais en particulier des
terrains année par exemple voilà le
moment le végétarianisme a énormément
gagné 1 je vois de plus en plus de mes
amis qui parlent de moins réduire
drastiquement leur consommation de
viande voir qu'ils deviennent végétarien
avoir qui deviennent vegan lit je pense
qu'il ya énormément de prouver aussi
dans tout ce qui est recherche sur les
alternatives à la viande avec des parts
dans des fosses viande à base de
lentilles ou ou d'autres légumineuses
qui sont que moi je trouve délicieuse
personnellement la viande cultivée aussi
progresse énormément avec une réduction
normes des plis même si bien sûr on n'y
est pas encore côté transports je pense
qu'il ya un normand de progrès la
voiture est calme de plus en plus
stigmatisés les solutions de covoiturage
sont non plus promu le train ainsi vont
les avions sont parqués en ce moment
c'est pas drôle et les villes se
s'adapter de plus en plus à vos vélos
beaucoup plus qu'aux voitures est
beaucoup plus agréable par exemple de
prendre le vélo aujourd'hui qu'il ne
l'était il ya même trois ans donc bon
c'est sans doute encore très insuffisant
mais ça serait erroné de dire qu'on ne
peut rien faire il ya beaucoup de choses
qui ont été faites il ya beaucoup de
progrès qui a eu lieu et je pense que
c'est intéressant de souligner est de
montrer que chacun peut vraiment
contribué avec ses différents gestes
plutôt que de considérer que le choix
enfants le
une espèce d'effondrement par exemple
des civilisations est quelque chose
d'inévitable et d'être un peu fataliste
par rapport à tout ça ce qu'on est en
face à 10 par rapport à tout ça il ya
risque d'un puissance acquise
alors une chose sur laquelle je dis
j'actionne insiste beaucoup et je vais
aussi beaucoup insisté dessus du coup
pour terminer cette vidéo c'est le fait
qu' il ne s'agit absolument pas de faire
l'inversé c'est à dire ne parler que des
solutions donne l'impression que que
tout ira bien
il ya un juste milieu à trouver entre
souligné les problèmes en jeu il faut
parler des problèmes dire que les choses
sont ne vont pas il ya beaucoup de
d'énormes risques mais à ce que dira
j'ai dit jacques sonne c'est qu'il faut
aussi mentionner un peu mais pas non
plus tout le temps les pistes de
solution les progrès qui ont lieu pour
ne serait-ce qu avoir une vision plus
juste de l'état des problèmes mais
également pour éviter du coup ce
problème de la pratique de l'impuissance
acquise du coup vous invite à vous aussi
à assier de ce que avec sociaux on est
tous un peu journalistes malheureusement
pas aujourd'hui et du coup on contribue
tout sera potentiellement oublié de
négativité et du coup je vous invite à
prendre soin de sa sur vos différents
réseaux sociaux à la fois la manière
dont vous partager mais vous pouvez
aussi choisir ce que vous pour vous vous
en fait changer les systèmes de
recommandations avec les différentes
options en disant qu'elles sont les
vidéos ou les études par exemple que
vous ne voulez pas avoir de sorte que ce
que vous partagez
est ce que vous lisez correspondent à un
meilleur équilibre entre les problèmes
et les solutions de nos sociétés
modernes